alors cette question qui pourra avoir
véritablement accès à ce traitement
l'argent est-il le nerf de la guerre
sanitaire c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
soit vous avec laurent alexandre et cic
chirurgien bonsoir laurent alexandre
merci d'être avec nous elle ses côtés
bonsoir jérôme marty médecin généraliste
président de l'union française pour une
médecine et bonsoir à vous aussi jérôme
marty alors docteur martien vous vous
avez repoussé un coup de gueule lundi
soir sur twitter avant de le commenter
je vous propose de le revoir de le
réécouter 2360 dollars pour cinq jours
de traitement partout dans le monde pour
un traitement qui n'a pas fait la preuve
de son efficacité autorisations
demandées par agence européenne du
médicament
on se fout vraiment de notre gueule
alors voilà ça mérite de la clarté
jérôme marty qu'est ce qui vous dérange
le plus dans cette affaire crée que ce
soit trop cher ou pas assez efficace
non ce qui me dérange c'est que les
rênes d élire pas plus que hydroxy
chlorure le chloroquine a fait la preuve
réelle de son efficacité
on nous parle d'un traitement qui est un
traitement compassionnel on nous parle
d'un traitement qui diminue le nombre de
jours de maladie de quinze jours en
moyenne à 11 jours mais qui n'a
absolument pas de diminuer le taux de
létalité de la maladie en tout cas de
façon très très faible et pas pas
significatives et là on nous vend des
médicaments dont le prix a été fixé sur
le prix de journée moyens
d'hospitalisation c'est à dire comme il
ya cinq jours de moins
d'hospitalisations on a fait 5 x x le
prix de journée on a défini de 1360
euros fait bon c'est tout ça était du
domaine plus financier que véritablement
médicale laurent l'exemple ce diagnostic
effectivement vu comme ça ça semble
choquant très cher et pas nécessairement
efficaces ont choqué il faudra
certainement prouver alors il faut pas
se monter le bourrichon le rêve désir
n'est quasiment pas utilisée dans le
coronavirus c'est une molécule qui est
très efficace dans l'hépatite c qui est
efficace aussi dans les mollahs mais qui
a une efficacité très modérée comme l'a
dit très justement
r dans le coronavirus il y à une
diminution de la durée d'hospitalisation
qui n'est pas nul
et puis il y à une baisse non
significative statistiquement de la
mortalité et on ne peut pas affirmer que
cette différence de mortalité convoi
dans l'étude n'est pas lié à un hasard
statistiques ça dépasse ça n'est pas
certain d'un point de vue statistique
aujourd'hui très très peu de gens
prescrivent du rem désire donc en
réalité c'est pas un enjeu extrêmement
important parce que cette molécule peu
efficaces et très peu prescrite
donc ce n'est pas un enjeu majeur de
santé publique on pourrait s'inquiéter
si c'était un médicament extrêmement
efficace comme sont les médicaments dont
la md et vire dans l'hépatite c ou les
médicaments dans le hiv mais là on a un
médicament peu efficace qui ne sera de
toute façon pas prescrits par rapport à
la ligue roc cyclo rockin je suis
d'accord avec mon confrère des tranchées
plan kidnappa c'est la preuve de son
efficacité leadership grand quine
effectivement n'est pas cher mais c'est
pas parce qu'un médicament et pas cher
qu'il faut l'utiliser
le prix n'est pas le premier facteur qui
rentrent en ligne de compte le premier
facteur c'est l'efficacité
si on regardait que le prix ont prescrit
ray de la médecine charlatanesques comme
l'homéopathie à nos patients mais il
semblerait avec différence avec hydroxy
chloroquine que les rênes d hiver n'a
pas été mis de côté mais au bon il n'y a
pas eu ce débat acharné comme l'a été
cette molécule préconisée par le
professeur raoul tu jérôme marty
justement comment vous expliquer cette
différence entre guillemets de
traitement est ce que des corps d'abord
vous êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic de
différence de traitement entre les deux
molécules
oui non je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
mon confrère laurent alexandre skis et
ski et ski est très curieux dans cette
affaire m déservir c'est le la demande
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché par
l'union européenne qui est assez
curieuse parce que comme comme l'a dit
très justement laurent alexandre c'est
un produit qui n'a pas fait la preuve de
son efficacité en tout cas sur la part
diminution de létalité on utilise un
protocole compassionnel c'est à dire
qu'on le donne en dernier recours
vraiment on ne peut rien faire d'autre
mais pourquoi pas défini à ce moment là
un prix de 2000 360 euros la semaine
pour je veux dire c'est pas la règle
habituelle qu habituellement on va vous
dire ce produit en termes de recherche a
coûté tant en termes de matériel à côté
tant en termes humains a coûté tant en
terme de durée a coûté temps et à partir
de là on fait un ratio et on définit le
coût du médicament en sachant qu' il va
toucher x partie de la population et on
va voir s'il peut être pris en charge
par les assurances sociales des pays et
c'est là on le définit en fonction de
l'économie fait en durée
d'hospitalisation
c'est rien je veux dire c'est plus de la
poésie que la médecine
un collectif un laissons les médecins à
prescrire c'était mur lundi soir dans
une lettre ouverte
l agence du daigné du médicament
dénonçant ce site un blanc-seing accordé
par l' agence européenne justement
aurait même désir le collectif demande à
l'agent sa transparence totale sur les
données de pharmacovigilance pour rire
aussi chloroquine et lorraine délire ça
veut dire quoi qu' un doute sur
l'honnêteté que les médecins ne
craignent une forme de manipulation au
profit de deux petits laurent alexandre
oh écoutez franchement je ne pense
vraiment pas qu'il y a de corruption à
la f10 et aux états unis et à l'agencé
européenne du médicament et dans les
agences nationales du médicament
pourquoi la crainte
cette crainte a émergé parce que quand
il s'est avéré que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine n'était pas efficace
didier rahout pour noyer le poisson a
expliqué qu'il y avait un complot de
gilles ead pour contrer l'hydroxyde
chloroquine à et maîtres lorraine d
élire à la place
en réalité c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe puisque leur désir n'est pas
prescrit donc il ya une crainte qui a
été montée en épingle par didier raoul
et si vous prenez les vidéos youtube de
didier raoul depuis quelques semaines il
y en a beaucoup qui sont consacrés à
gillet à ça lui permet de faire oublier
le fait que même aux états unis où trump
avait beaucoup beaucoup poussé hydroxy
chloroquine on l'a retiré des
médicaments autorisés dans le colis de
19 et vous imaginez bien que si
l'hydroxyde chloroquine marchait
à 120 jours des élections
présidentielles 30 n'aurait pas interdit
le protocole de raout il n'est pas
masochiste il ne veut pas perdre
l'élection aura hoult donc de pardon
trompe donc le fait que les états unis
aient interdit la molécule prouve bien
que ça n'est pas efficace après que le
président ait énormément poussé la
molécule dans un premier temps quand il
a cru que c'était efficace
donc non il n'y a pas de complot contre
l'hydre auxi chloroquine et en faveur du
rêve d élire mais je partage tout à fait
le point de vue de mon confrère marty
l'hydroxyde chloroquine ne marche pas du
tout et lorraine des et vire à une
efficacité modeste nul sur la mortalité
et puis c'est bhl sur la durée
d'hospitalisation donc leur md et vit
dans cette maladie là contrairement à
d'autres maladies comme l'hépatite c ou
c très efficace le remdh et elvire n'est
pas un remède extraordinaire c'est une
molécule qui apporte un tout petit plus
on va relativiser mais en tout cas les
états unis ont quasiment acheter
l'intégralité des stocks
jérôme marty vous êtes d'accord avec cet
agnostique de laurent alexandre c'est
didier raoult qui a monté un petit peu
cette polémique
on n'est pas un jérôme ma fille n'ont
jamais manqué celui du médecin
généraliste du cros place hier il faut
se mettre à notre place où depuis le
début dans cette affaire qu'il a fait un
raid roxy qui eux mêmes des zi he et
cetera on est bien trop serré la plume
c'est à dire que on est au milieu des
pro et des anti et on compte que les
cours et nous on a nos patients qui tous
les jours nous demandent est ce que ce
médicament est efficace
est-ce que je peux le prendre et ce que
je dois prendre et on est dans
l'incapacité réel de leur répondre parce
que il n'y a pas eu d'études académiques
d'études formelle sur la base du
protocole qu'avaient défini par exemple
le professeur yao qui nous aurait permis
de dire aux patients n'ont été volées
désolé mais ça ne marche pas ou écouter
oui ça marche donc on est dans une
espèce de no man's land depuis le début
avec avec très peu de possibilités
scientifiques de dire non est content et
on est certain
ça ne marche pas donc là pour l'instant
selon pas dire au patient le tout récent
et ça c'est important c'est que
malheureusement cette affection ne nous
a pas quittés
malheureusement le virus circule
malheureusement il circule même beaucoup
il circule chez des jeunes des jeunes
actifs qui font défendre position
automatique ou asymptomatiques donc on
ne le voit pas il est encore plus
invisible que si tu pouvais être à une
époque mais ça ne veut pas dire qu' il
ne peut pas exploser un moment ou un
autre et que cette fameuse deuxième
vague de cette fameuse poussée
n'adviendra pas soit pendant l'été soit
après l'été donc il faut continuer à
porter le masque en lieu clos c'est une
affection des lieux clos ce n'est pas
une affection de l'extérieur c'est une
affection le club ça il faut partir là
dessus il faut ouvrir le col est il faut
aérer
il faut respecter les mesures barrières
et continuer parce que malheureusement
le virus ne nous a pas quittés et on va
avoir nous médecins sans doute un rôle à
jouer encore important dans les semaines
qui viennent laurent alexandre c'est
important ce que nous digérons marcoux
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
polémiqué la deuxième vague semble
guetter vous vous êtes justement inquiet
aujourd'hui qu'est la réaction c'est
profond justement je suis je suis
d'accord avec partie la probabilité
qu'ils aient une deuxième vague et est
relativement forte il y à une deuxième
vague en ce moment même aux états unis
et en israël par exemple il faut donc
être extrêmement vigilant et c'est pour
ça que j'ai trouvé extrêmement léger la
déclaration de raul qu'il ya un mois
expliquant qu'il n'y aurait jamais de
deuxième vague ce qui pousse les gens à
lever les à lever le pied sur les
précautions et sur les gestes barrières
il n'est pas raisonnable de dire je suis
certain qu'il n'y aura pas de deuxième
vingt quand on est dit raul tu parce que
cela incite les gens à prendre des
risques et on voit déjà dans deux pays
israël et les états unis qui ne sont pas
des pays sous-développés 1
on voit une deuxième vague la deuxième
vague en israël elle est spectaculaire
et elle est à peu près synchrone de
celle qui a eu lieu aux états unis alors
aux états unis on a des différences
entre les différents états mais la
californie l'arkansas l'arizona la
floride ont une explosion exponentielle
du nombre de cas il faut qu'on soit très
vigilant si ça arrive là bas ça peut
tout à fait arriver chez nous la
deuxième vague
merci à tous les deux laurent alexandre
et jérôme marty d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir des bêtes fait ensemble
avec sur rt france merci